اعلنت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه استشهاد
اربعه فلسطينيين برصاص قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي خلال اقتحامها مخيم الفارعه
جنوبي طوباس في الضفه الغربيه وكانت قوات
خاصه اسرائيليه قد تسللت الى مخيم الفارعه
وبعد اكتشافها دفع الجيش الاحتلال جيش
الاحتلال بتعزيزات الى داخل المخيم واعتل
القناص اسطح البنايات قبل ان تندلع
مواجهات في المكان وقد اندلعت مواجهات مع
الشبان الفلسطينيين اطلقت خلالها قوات
الاحتلال الرصاص الحي والغاز على
المواطنين ما ادى الى وقوع اصابات بينما
عرقلت عمل الطواقم الطبيه وسياره
الاسعاف متابعه الوضع في هذه المنطقه
تحديدا في الفارعه معنا من مخيم الفارعه
جنوب طوباس مراسل الجزيره ليث جعار ليث
ماذا عن
الوضع
نعم انسحبت اليات الاحتلال العسكريه قبل
لحظات من مخيم الفارع على وقع عمليه
عسكريه استمرت قرابه الساعه حيث وصلت قوات
خاصه اسرائيليه الى احدى المناطق في مخيم
الفارعه ومن ثم بدات الدفع بالتعزيز
العسكريه الاسرائيليه نحو المخيم اغلقت
كافه المداخل المؤديه الى المخيم نحن هنا
نرقب هذه الصوره من مكان تحام الاحتلال
لمنطقه المخيم حيث وصلت عشرات الاليات
العسكريه برفقه جرافه الى هذه المنطقه
وصولا الى مخيم الفارع الذي يظهر في هذه
الصوره وبدات الاشتباكات المسلحه وتفجير
لعشرات العبوات الناسفه باليات الاحتلال
العسكريه قناصه الاحتلال استهدفت مجموعه
من الشبان ادى ذلك لارتقاء اربعه شهداء وا
ويعني عدد من الاصابه تم نقلهم الى
المستشفى التركي في محافظه طوباس انسحب
الاحتلال و لا تزال يعني بين الفينه
والاخرى هناك نقل لاصابات من اماكن متعدده
في محيط الباس اثناء انسحاب الاحتلال من
هذا الطريق تم استهداف مجموعه من الشبان
يعني على الاقل على الاقل تم نقل ثلاثه
اصابات نحو المستشفى التركي في محافظه
طوباس هذه العمليه العسكريه جاءت بعد يوم
واحد فقط من اقتحام جنين واستمرار
للعمليات العسكريه او اقتحام طول كرم عفوا
واستمرارا للعمليات العسكريه على ما يبدو
ان هناك حديث الان عن اصابه نعم على ما
يبدو انه هناك اصابه جديده اثناء انسحاب
الاحتلال من منطقه بلده طمون الى الشرق
من المخيم وفي هذه الاثناء على ما يبدو ان
الاسعاف باشرت بالوصول بعد بلاغ عن اصابه
وصلت ايه او ايه تمت في محيط بلده طمون في
هذه اللحظات الاحتلال منذ قرابه الساعه
حاصر المخيم منع الطواقم الطبيه منع
الطواقم الصحفيه من الوصول الى اي نقطه
قريبه من المخيم
اي وقف الاحتلال وحاصر المركبات حاول
اطلاق النار صوب اي مركبه او اي جسم متحرك
في المنطقه يحاول الوصول الى مخيم الفارعه
منذ هذا الصباح في هذه الاثناء انسحب
الاحتلال باتجاه حاجز الحمراء وهو الحاجز
الذي لا يبعد سوى 10 كيلومترات عن مخيم
الفارع او عن محافظه طوباس و تاركا خلفه
اربعه شهداء حتى هذه اللحظه واعداد
الاصابات حقيقه لم يعني يتم احصاء حتى هذه
اللحظه نتيجه لاستمرار وتوافد ووصول
الاصابات الى ايه المستشفى التركي في في
المحافظه شكرا لك ليث جعار كنت معنا من
جنوب طوباس